be huge no because I just love you
slingin all you've been slinging the
Mexican jokes at oh yeah for so many
years I've done that all right so I got
my DNA test 23andme ancestry why did you
guys there are sponsors oh [ __ ] we can
cut that out
no no no here's a weird thing yeah I'll
tell you what happens here's what I'm
gonna do I am at 20 I am gonna do I'm
gonna do there's a well there is a
cheaper version out of Tijuana called
faint they dressy or $15 oh my god no
tell me it's a real thing oh I told my
family so um here's the weird thing
actually all of my family did 23andme
here I ended up I ended up doing
ancestry for this reason and I called 23
me to ask them about this first if you
know that you have some Portuguese in
your in your family and you and you get
a get your DNA you're gonna get your DNA
done it's really good you
they don't 23 me does not split up they
don't split up you can take all this out
yeah they don't split up Spain and
Portugal Spain and Portugal they put is
one and it's Iberian so you're gonna get
that information back but you're not
gonna quite know what percentage is what
ancestry just about nine months ago
figured it out and they're now
separating Spain and Portugal hmm and I
found this out because you know how many
Portuguese friends I have and the San
Joaquin Valley is a ton of them over
there right yeah and they're like oh no
now we know and they're gonna oh well
then I need to know cuz I knew my mom
one thing we knew about my mom is that
she was half she's half Mexican and half
Portuguese right so my all my family did
they them they're like oh well we're I'm
40% Iberian or I'm 3849 but I was like
but what what's your port where are
where's your Portuguese and where's your
space whatever so I get my do you know
you know I've been telling everybody my
whole life
I'm like I'm pretty much Mexican I'm
like I'm probably 80% Mexican I bet I
have maybe 10 15 percent Portuguese so
I'm 38 percent Portuguese 33 percent
Mexican and 21 percent Spanish hmm so
I'm more you're Mexican
I'm more but all that so you're [ __ ]
Mexican I'm but but if you add the
Portuguese and the Spanish together
that's think that doesn't 60% Iberian
code that don't do and 30% Mexican that
don't do [ __ ] for me bro
oh why do you gotta start acting like
you're talking like a cholo or something
I'm not acting like you're all Mexican
bro okay but anyway look I don't care it
but here's what's weird for me I told
you growing up in the San Joaquin Valley
I for some reason I I gravitated to all
these Portuguese friends in high school
during grade school and all that other
he was whites
it was blacks and it was you know
Mexicans but in high school I made a lot
of these Portuguese friends because they
were out in different schools because
they have Gary's and farms out there
right that's the majority of the people
that you get your haagen-dazs and your
and your cheese and all that [ __ ] it's
all these Portuguese dairy people right
yeah and all they do all the produce and
all that [ __ ] too so I grew up with I'm
going to their festas growing up out
there I'm literally the only Mexican
they would give me [ __ ] sometimes like a
[ __ ] dude what's this Mexican dude do it
at our Portuguese Festa again every
single [ __ ] year huh and now I have
no idea why you were the going you had a
sense but I believe in that [ __ ] right
like I believe I was gravitating towards
the people that I that I'm funny you say
that because when I do I love sushi and
I'm always eating sushi I am but I'm 10%
Japanese Oh Ted okay well think about
the surprise the same thing 38 percent
that's it oh no we're dealing with like
percentages the end that's is that what
you do you're doing but listen I am
gonna get just nine point nine so I'm a
head well I rounded up to 40 I'm going
on 40 and then I'm through
and so what you're saying is you're
Christiano Ronaldo you're trying to say
because you look you don't look anything
like him
you're like let me let me say something
right now dude right I'm gonna let you
go or check if in Portugal if they had
Fraggles yeah we're like little
creatures living into the walls with
little mystical caves right then I'd be
like oh yeah that's that but let me say
it something right now dude right you're
[ __ ] weird-looking wrong okay right
your fucked-up eyes and but you're a
good dude you have a lot of talent and
that's why you're here don't be throwing
that [ __ ] heat in here okay you're
[ __ ] two facts okay love you so much
though let me I'm gonna write I'm gonna
ride that that doing [ __ ] looking wave
for a second with you yeah I'm with you
okay so then I get this information and
I start sitting back and I start getting
pissed off right yeah cuz I'm looking at
Portuguese you seen the players the
Portuguese soccer players yeah like
you're talking about the the Spanish the
Spaniards oh [ __ ] yeah do you all yeah
all those guys are good looking or and I
get up you all five nothing cricket dude
I'm serious I was really I was so mad
about that I gotta have more of a
European yeah all right dude I could
have look like a [ __ ] conquested or
[ __ ] soccer player dude yeah it's
like having vanilla ice cream right
let's you you're at a baskin-robbins
right but some of the other flavors got
in right
it ruins kind of yeah the pureness the
pureness of it you really shouldn't on
Mexicans right now I love them so much I
love the fiestas oh now it's them I love
now it's not me guitar playing is wicked
identity crisis when I first came from
the Philippines and I was Mexican all
throughout high school
oh well yeah they know wait do you know
wait wait wait out of all of you here
since that's the sponsor and I am
getting it done cuz I'm gonna have a
double check yeah it's fine cuz my
family no seriously
yes I'm talking about ancestry listen
because we're cutting all of it out no
no but here's the artist still is before
my fam
since my parents and my three sisters
two sisters did that 23 me I'm gonna do
it anyway also his backup just to make
sure that the information I got is it's
pretty accurate so I'm doing it anyway
but I just wanted to know what my
Portuguese was and I called I did call
23 million ask her about it okay
congratulations
and by the way is that what you hear for
me by the way to hear that from me
congratulations let's give a whisper out
to the 23 ma they take that I see y'all
is that it
I mean you see at this gigantic reveal
and that was like I thought you would be
more like what you're that I heard that
you're like your max again yours the
years that that that was literally the
last episode of Game of Thrones I was
like
[Music]